لا يمكن إنكار حجم الخسائر المدنية وتدمير
البنية التحتية المدنية في أوكرانيا ،
فهذا يتطلب تحقيقًا شاملاً
ومساءلة
[موسيقى]
بين 24 فبراير و 15
مارس سجل مكتب المفوض السامي
لحقوق الإنسان
900 ضحية مدنية
، ويتألف المجموع من
726.  قُتل شخصًا بينهم 52 طفلاً
و
1،174 جريحًا من بينهم 63 طفلاً ،
ستتم محاسبة روسيا على
فظائعها.
هناك
طريقة واحدة فقط لإنهاء هذا الجنون ،
الرئيس بوتين ،
أوقف القتل ،
واسحب قواتك ، اترك أوكرانيا مرة واحدة وإلى الأبد
[موسيقى]
الذي
تحقق من 463 هجومًا على الرعاية الصحية
أسفر عن مقتل 12 شخصًا
وإصابة 34 آخرين ،
بمن فيهم العاملون الصحيون
في أي نزاع على الرعاية
الصحية ، يعد انتهاكًا للقانون الإنساني الدولي ،
حيث يحرمون الأشخاص من
الرعاية التي يحتاجون إليها بشكل عاجل ويكسرون
الأنظمة الصحية المقيدة بالفعل